hello
and thank you for joining us for today's
presentation
part of our agilent cell analysis global
conference
my name is yama abbasi and i'm the vice
president of business development at
asia biosciences
which is now part of agilent
technologies
and i'll be your host for today's
presentation
before i introduce our speaker for today
allow me to share a bit about
agilent and our products for cell
analysis
agilent as a leader in life sciences is
very focused on enabling our customers
to gain the insights they seek
a rapidly growing cell analysis
portfolio
enables deeper more reliable insights
across a variety of cell analysis
applications
where investigators and drug developers
seek to understand
dynamic cellular environments and
interactions
this is critically important in the
large
and growing immuno-oncology and
immunotherapy fields
for example discovering safe
potent and persistent immune cell
products
requires a more comprehensive
understanding
of cancer biology and immune cell
function
our presentation today will specifically
uh address this and and other solutions
that are being implied in this
context our speaker for today
is dr christopher deronzo who is a
pediatric
oncologist um he joined
the department of bone marrow transpl
plantation and cellular therapy
at st jude's children's research
hospital
where his goal is to develop and
translate promising cell therapies
from the laboratory into clinical trials
for pediatric patients with solid tumors
and brain tumors prior to joining
st jude he performed his general
pediatric training at case western
reserve university
rainbow babies and children's hospital
and pediatric hematology oncology
training at baylor college of medicine
in texas
and texas children's cancer and
hematology centers
we stayed on as a faculty until
transitioning to his new role at st jude
he grew up in southern new jersey and we
had a
very lively discussion about the
life in southern new jersey versus some
of the other places that
dr dorenzo has been uh which is
uh and and he really never
imagined living in cleveland houston or
memphis but has enjoyed
living in each of these great cities and
getting to know the people from diverse
parts of the u.s and
also all over the world before i hand it
over to chris
a couple of housekeeping notes they will
be question and answer
period immediately following the talk
and to help us
get as many of your questions as
possible we encourage you to
please type in your questions during the
presentation
and with that i will hand it over to
chris
yama thank you so much for the kind
introduction it's an incredible pleasure
to be able to give this talk i'm going
to talk about
our experience using b7h3
car t cells and the real goal as
mentioned
is is to treat patients pediatric
patients with solid tumors and brain
tumors
of course this could be used for adult
patients but here at st
jude you know all of our focus is on on
children with
catastrophic diseases i do have one
disclosure that based on the the work
presented here we filed a patent
application for
b7h3 car t cells and
a non-specific disclosure i
am a big fan of the excellence machine
in agilent
i highly promote it but i have no
financial or otherwise interest in the
technology but i use it with great
enthusiasm
and i'll start just posing our our
simple
question is developing a clinical trial
using
car t cells for for patients this is
you know something we found out we want
to take from
the bench to the bedside and then what
is the optimal
uh car construct actually moved to the
clinical trial
um you know sort of broad picture why do
we
need car t cells a lot of people
watching this talk
or or later on on video certainly know
the reasons but i always like to start
with this
is pediatric patients and adult patients
once their cell tumor has spread or come
back after
frontline conventional treatment you
know their prognosis is extremely poor
and then as many of us know especially
clinicians that work with patients
you know are conventional cytotoxic
chemotherapies
radiation and surgery while they're
incredibly
useful in gold standard of care they
have late effects and
and side effects that we hope to
minimize and
car t cells have non-over overlapping
toxicities so they usually do not make
these worse
and you know what sort of reason do we
have to believe
that that t cells will work for
pediatric patients with solid tumors
now there's really been pretty
remarkable successes
with t cells for some types of cancer
patients with epstein-barr virus
positive lymphomas have had nice success
using ebv specific t
cells steve rosenberg and group at the
nih and others have shown that
tumor infiltrating lymphocytes can
really massively decrease the size of
some large melanomas which is quite
remarkable
and the most one is genetically modified
t cells targeting cd19
um two cd19 car t cell products have
approval
and we're using them here at st jude and
everybody is around the world
and response rates in the 80 plus
percent
for patients with relapse b cell
leukemia
which obviously is quite remarkable
so we do have great you know we think
there's great potential in using car t
cells to treat patients with solid
tumors
but it's very challenging cell tumors
and liquid tumors are not the same
and specific to this talk when you look
at
pediatric cases they're very rare to
start with any individual solid tumor
and we really want to find targets that
we can treat
patients with different types of solid
tumors so the ideal target antigen
is not on simply osteosarcoma because
the number of patients will be very low
but
you know that we can treat multiple
tumor types to help a broader range of
patients
and then is the you know the big
challenge is
almost all antigens expressed on any
type of cancer
somewhere in the body it will be
expressed in normal tissues
so the real goal is to find targets that
have minimal expression on normal tissue
or more more realistically that there's
acceptable risk of targeting these and
of course
cd19 car is the classic because cd19 is
on our normal b
cells and with the advent of
um immune globulin infusions
you know people can survive quite nicely
with b-cell applausia
without serious side effects although
not you know completely ideal
so why b7h3 when i
first started looking at this years ago
there were reports out of sloan
kettering and now there's
others out of stanford um in the nih
that there's really limited expression
in normal tissues
there is some transient expression in
subsets of
immune cells which is not completely
worked out for humans
[Music]
its role in solid tumor biology
seems you know more and more evidence is
building that b7h3 actually
inhibits t cell function so certainly
makes sense that solid tumors would
express b7h3 at high levels to avoid
the adaptive immune response and
currently
uh macrogenics and other companies
are using b7h3 specific antibodies and
clinical trials for patients with solid
tumors
including pediatric patients which is
quite encouraging
and then there are studies pre-clinical
studies linking
b7h3 expression to tumor aggressiveness
metastatic disease and and sort of poor
outcomes but that is
is not proven yet so we wanted to take
our our own look uh what is b7h3 on
malignant
and normal tissues at saint jude and did
this
in collaboration with our gene editing
core
um chandra miller on the top left and
then mike clay and julie justice the
bottom right and pathology
and what this is showing is we did a
crispr cast 9
p7h3 knockout of lm7 cells which is
an osteosarcoma cell line that is
metastatic to the lungs and on the left
you can see
you know very little brown staining and
on the right
our lm7 wild type you have nice diffuse
immune hystochemical staining
and whereas lots of previous work
has used normal tissues we've really
found this to be a strong
positive and negative control we grew
these tumors up in mice made slides out
of them
and then sort of just to describe how we
determine
how positive or how strongly positive
tumors are
we used a semi-quantitative scoring
system
on the left zero plus is uh no staining
of
any level and one plus is simply mild
two moderate staining and three would be
high in
staining these are just relative
examples
um and again to sort of put this in a
semi-quantitative
we added up the sort of percent of cells
staining at one plus or two plus or
three plus
and divided by three hundred to get what
we call an
h score um commonly used in the field
and just to sort of indicate what this
means is a hundred percent of cells
standing strongly positive
would be a score of 300 in which divided
by 300 would
um you know or it could be 900 divided
by 300 so the maximal score is 300.
really how does this look very
consistent with
what other groups have found is we
drew a cutoff score of 100 determine
positive versus negative then that could
be argued that it should be lowered or
increased but that's what we went with
and found that a high number of
pediatric solid tumors
are positive for b7h3 on the left of
desmoplastic small round cell tumor
next to that ews is ewing sarcoma
surprisingly
um had much lower level expression than
we expected when other groups had found
very high levels
and it may just been our our sample
population or perhaps the antibody we
used in staining
in the middle is is nbl and next to that
os so neuroblastoma and osteosarcoma
and on the right the two different kinds
of rhabdomyosarcoma
and those are all very highly positive
and those four are the most
most common pediatric cell tumors that
would be
targeting and as you can see
many of the tumors have you know
completely
positive scores of 300 so how does this
look in in normal tissues well
something caught our eye relatively
immediately
if you see on the left adrenal tissue
which
other groups had described as moderately
positive
or or weak cytoplasmic staining
in our studies we use normal
non-neoplastic adrenal tissue taken from
patients that had their their kidneys
removed
and all of them were highly positive
which is a new finding
for the field liver positivity was
expected
and then mostly otherwise normal tissue
types were completely negative
or low staining so largely confirms
what's in the literature but i think
adds as
clinical trials are started we have to
be aggressive in monitoring for adrenal
insufficiency
and see if this will will hold true in
the clinic
so then knowing in our hands what's
truly positive and negative we look what
is
we start off by saying what is the
optimal um car backbone to build upon
to make um sort of the optimal car for
clinical translation and
from left to right feng nguyen emanuel
kiki and carla
o'reilly did all of this work
so a second generation car which
by now i i don't even have to give the
introductory slides on on cars but
cars have a single chain variable
fragment derived from monoclonal
antibodies that recognize
uh target antigen with the hc
restriction as do normal alpha beta tcrt
cells and on the left
you can see then dark blue a hinge
transmembrane domain
and then after that there's a cosine
domain and three zeta activation
here we use different combinations very
simple
of hinge transmembrane domains and
co-stem domain and wanted to ask the
question
does cd8 alpha hinge transmembrane
compared to cd28
make a difference and then does cd28
coast them or 401 bb
coast then make a difference and then
out of these four constructs what is
what is the best to move forward
um and these if one can say there are
standard constructs in the field these
would be the standard hinge
transmembrane and cosine domains that
most people start off with
although others could certainly be used
and the first question is sort of just
general does
using these car t cells effect
electrician of um
human t cells and we do that we use a
lentiviral system
so we take human peripheral blood
mononuclear cells and then do a cd4 cd8
selection and activation
we give cytokinesis 7 and 15 and then do
our our vsvg
pseudotype lentiviral transduction on
day one
and feed cytokines grow up and use the
cells
all these experiments are done seven to
ten days after
um transduction and to
lentiviral transduction aficionados
we use the multiplicity of infection
here of 50
and while that may seem high it's really
what gave us very
nice transduction levels and it
shouldn't be dangerous in any
any manner that we found so on the left
hand side here
i have the car transduction in vcn or
vector copy number
and you can immediately see that all the
constructs
successfully transduce t cells greater
than non-transduced which is
on the left in brown and the light blue
which has the cd8
28 trans membrane domain and cd28
co-stem domain
consistently had a very low vector copy
number
compared to all other t cell types
and when we look on the right side
percent of car positive cells
fits nicely with our vector copy number
data
so the sort of take-home message of this
is even though the constructs are
similar
um the one with the cd28 transmembrane
domain and co-stem domain
was consistently lower transduction and
you can see the stats there
um you know showed it's statistically
significant but to us this is
this is clinically relevant as if we're
having an
average carb positive of 35 40 percent
pre-clinically
patients treated with chemotherapy we
would expect to be much lower and it's
not a great place to start
so then does the car construct affect
effector function expansion apoptosis
cytokine secretion
and when we look at expansion while the
sort of differences might seem a little
bit minimal this is
day 10 after transduction we expand in
il-7 in il-15
in black you have the car with the cd8
alpha hinge transmembrane domain and c28
costin
blue also has the cd28 cosine compared
to those with 41 bb
co-stem domains those
expanded to greater levels and much
similar to our untransduced or
non-transduced t
cells and of course growing cells in gnp
conditions the full expansion is
critical that we get the cell numbers
that we need to treat patients
and we ask the question is this sort of
due to
cells just growing slower or perhaps are
they they dying
faster when we look on the right hand
side at a next and five positive cells
indicating basal apoptosis rate you know
the black circles and the blue
are lower compared to the green and red
which have 41 bb
co-stem domains and which is
the cars with 4 on bb cosim domains had
higher apoptosis levels
and sort of that fits some previous data
but then really the functional data
that's critical to moving forward is
you know how do these costume domains
and hinge transmembrane domains affect
function
so we did have the design on the left
our co-culture the t cells to tumor
cells is a one-to-one ratio we just we
did elisa
importantly we do t cells only to look
at
interferon gamma secretion you know at
baseline
and then we have our positive and
negative targets here we use
osteosarcoma cells lm7
a549 which is adult lung cancer u373
which is a brain tumor high grade glioma
cell line
so simply put all the cars specifically
recognize
the b7 h3 positive targets
compared to our lm7 knockout which is
b7h3
negative but i draw your attention to
the
the red asterisks particularly the
green bar and red bar and media alone
and that's showing that the cars with
401 bb co-stem domains are producing
interferon gamma without any
um stimulation or reckon recognition of
tumor lines positive for b7 h3
and that holds true against the b7h3
knockout
alone i think it's critically relevant
that you know other groups and
publications and what's moving the
clinical trials at other institutions
at least as far as i know and one
clinical trial open july 23rd
is that that would be this green bar has
a cd8 alpha hinge transmembrane domain
and 401 bb co-stem domain and while i'm
not
saying that it is the bad car and our
our findings it does have some tonic
signaling and when we look at il-2
production which um
predicts proliferation and
persistence after injection or infusion
into patients
um the cars with cd28 co-stim domains
against all the positive cell lines
the black and the blue have
significantly greater il2 compared to
the green and the red
which have 41 bb coast in so really the
cars with 401 bb costume domain do have
tonic
activation and limited il2 secretion
which was a little bit of a red flag to
us
so really this is where we
turn to our um our use of the
accelergence and ask do
second generation cars repeatedly kill
tumor cells and
you know as opposed to sort of do s
cells car t cells kill once
um a hundred percent uh i don't think
that's as relevant and here's a little
bit of a
depiction of how this works so we take
our car t cells we incubate them with
lm7 osteosarcoma cells and then we're
able to gently remove the t
cells off of the adherent cells
plate them on fresh ln7 cells
for a second stimulation three to four
days later
and then we get an example readout on
the y-axis here is a
normalized cell index that we get from
our
cell impedance assay using the agilent
accelerance machine
and the x-axis is time in hours
so the normalized cell index can be
converted
using a calculation to sell killing but
on this the higher the y-axis
you have the closer to one you basically
have a hundred percent
live cells so in the pink you have
tumor cells only which i mean nothing
the black is our control car that has no
cd3
activation domain there's no killing and
in this example the orange which um
unfortunately i couldn't change the
color to make consistent with other
other things but in this one donor c8
alpha cd28 had the highest killing
so given our previous data it's
sort of difficult to summarize all of
this because
different human donors you know we don't
know how many times they will kill
and each can kill different numbers so
you see on the left
on first stimulation as predicted by
you know multiple studies we've done the
car t cells kill targets 100 percent
whereas control t cells when the tumor
cells alone
have only background um cytotoxic
or tumor killing and that's in the
middle it shows sort of all of our
different donors
very consistent with all the donors and
to find some way to combine all of this
data
we basically repeated this stimulation
assay until
quite simply that the donor stopped
killing so you can see this dashed line
for each donor on the right
is that 50 killing so we would say
for each of those you know that donor
has clearly
stopped killing and to summarize the
data
the stimulation right before that where
you do still have greater than 50
percent killing of any t-cell type we
call a final stimulation
as a way to to collate our data
and you know a little bit surprising
i would have hypothesized that the the t
cells with tonic signaling would be
significantly decreased
uh killing in these repeat killing
assays you know most of the car t
cells were were similar as you can see
the black
the light blue and the green have very
similar cytosis
over time um however we were able to
sort of say that the one with the cd28
hinged transmembrane and 41 bb costing
had
was significantly lower than the others
and
mainly use that data to
not use that construct later in vivo
so i'm going to give a brief summary so
far
you know our data really showed us that
the b7h street cars with 401 bb
co-stimulation have tonic signaling
um a high basal apoptosis rate limited
il-2 secretion
but as i just showed the killing over
time
was similar to other cars so we
certainly couldn't rule this out
as a competitor to move move forward
clinically
the car with the cd28 transmembrane
domain and co-stem had low transduction
and overall which i call the sort of
best
uh so far was the cda alpha hinge
transmembrane and cd28 coastin
and that's on the right now is just a
picture
showing how we viewed it at at this
point and could certainly be argued but
i think the data becomes clear
a little bit later that the
the car t cell depicted in black has the
overall best
effector function so we wanted to to ask
the question
does adding 401 bb co-stimulation
enhance the function
of of this so far best performing second
generation car
and we use two methods to do this the
first is very standard in the field
simply added a 401 bb
co-stimulation domain to the endo domain
of the car so it has both cd28
co-stimulation
and 401 bb co-stimulation
the second method which is pioneered by
michelle satellin's group and has been
used for cd19 car t
cells and it's being used clinically for
those
while not tested yet for second
generation cars with solid tumors
we express 41b big and
constitutively on the cell surface and
when t
cells are activated they up regulate the
receptor 41 bb
and you either get self binding of the 4
on bb ligand
the 4 receptor or t cells next to each
other can activate their
their nearest neighbor to provide
additional co-stimulation
and just from these sample um
uh dot plots the transduction levels for
all of these was
was quite high we got very very nice on
the bottom right
expression of b7a street car and 401 bb
ligand and this was uh i
know this free data here but very nice
transduction for all of our constructs
for all of
our donors and i don't the
interferon gamma and il-2 data for these
was very similar
but where we really started to see a
difference was in this again in this
repeat killing essay
on the left we have the first
stimulation of course
um as expected all the car t cells kill
a hundred percent of targets whereas the
controls have minimal or no
killing and that is nearly identical
across four
donors and when you show it
the individual donors it becomes quite
clear
that the red or the forum bb ligand car
is able to to kill repeatedly
and is is the best in each of the donors
and when you summarize this it's
significantly higher killing
which is something that we've only seen
in repeat stimulation essays so it helps
tease out a little bit or or a lot for
us
that this might be the car to move
forward clinically now of course we need
um in vivo data and
we wanted to next take a look at you
know really
how do all of these function in vivo the
first
in vivo model that we use is is
is sort of a just a quick test we inject
on day zero um one million
osteosarcoma cells we do it
intraperitoneal
which is not an orthotopic location for
osteosarcoma
but it's it's a very quick way for us to
get an idea if car t cells will work in
vivo
seven days later we inject a very low
number
of t cells only a hundred thousand um
ip and then see how the results and this
done in collaboration with our our
center for
in vivo imaging and therapeutics um
walter on the left and rebecca on the
right are fantastic
um and when we look at sort of all the
the data together if you look at the top
we have
radiance or sort of cumulative tumor
volume
over time and that stays post-tumor cell
injection
in black we have clear anti-tumor
activity
and quite surprising in light blue and
green
that these two constructs even though
they do kill
very well on the first stimulation and
some donors on subsequent stimulations
very little anti-tumor activity in this
model
and when we add 401 bb ligand
we can't see much of an improvement
because 100 percent of the mice are
are surviving basically at this point
whereas the
third generation car the dark blue
compared to the black
um adding 401 bb coast them to the endo
domain
uh clearly appears to limit its
uh anti-tumor activity in vivo at least
in this model
so next we we took a look at a different
model a549 is a pretty aggressive
lung cancer inject that tail vein
to grow cancers in the lungs and then
seven days later inject three million t
cells
and we largely find the same results is
that the second generation car
um in black with the cd8 alpha hinge
transmembrane and c28 costin
has anti high anti-tumor activity
leading to
you know sig you know very high survival
after
tumor cell injection the light blue the
green and the dark blue
have minimal anti-tumor activity um
and without really increasing survival
in mice and the 4mb legging car
um appeared similar to the second the
best
performing second generation car and
when we looked at a
more lengthy model where we inject
osteosarcoma cells into the tail vein
and they form lung metastatic disease
which is the metastatic orthotopic site
that we see in humans
and then 28 days later after letting
them
seed and grow in the lungs inject a
million t
cells which is a relatively low number
we find that although there is
you know a modest increase the car with
4 ohm bb ligand
is performing best in our orthotopic
lung metastatic or
systemic osteosarcoma model
and if you notice in all of these i
mentioned the green
car with cd8 alpha 4 on bb is being
moved forward
in at least my prediction
multiple clinical trials based on papers
and personal communications
while it may be there is high anti-tumor
activity published in other models
using the same scfe here it appears that
it
doesn't function as well or have high
anti-tumor activity
in our hands at least in these models
so as an overall summary of what we find
is that the cars with the 401 bb co-stem
domain
do not function as well as those with cd
28
and the car with the cd8 alpha hinge
transmembrane domain and cd28 is the
overall best second generation car
when we add 401 bb ligand constitutive
expression to the surface um
with the repeat killing assay and at
least one out of
our in-vivo models you have improved
anti-tumor activity although it's
it's not a home run it does look better
to us and when you add a 401 bb
coast them and make it a third
generation car it
it hinders car t cell function or
decreases the overall effector function
of that second generation car so
and sort of wrap it up you know b7 h3
car t cells are very promising as
b7h3 is expressed at a high level on
multiple solid
tumors making it a highly relevant
product for clinical translation
it does have low expression on normal
tissues but very hard to predict
side effects before we go into patients
and that will we will be looking at
side effects especially related to liver
and adrenal
expression of b7h3 definitely hinge
transmembrane and costing domains affect
car function
and despite all of the technology that
we have there's
you know these results can only be found
empirically by comparing
cars against one another in detail
assays as described here
um hopefully there's a way to predict
um before doing all these assays
but as of now it's very empiric and have
to compare that
compare them together adding 401 bb
to the endo domain inhibits function as
i just discussed
whereas putting 401 bb ligand on the
surface expression
enhances car t cell function at least to
some
extent and i highlight in blue that the
really the excellence impedance-based
astay
for us and and i do hope for others it's
been highly relevant
um for assessing car t cell function
um and there are you know there's a huge
amount of data that comes out of it
and i could have shown the graphs in
multiple different ways
um and as i was um uh discussing with
yama before this as a pi one of the
the great things about it in my opinion
in addition to all its uses
is i can go in and look at the data
immediately without having to wait for
postdocs and and staff to tell me
tell me how it's looking i can sneak in
and see the data at any time
there are a huge number of people that
have worked on this both in my lab
and our our bone marrow transplant cell
therapy department
i give special attention to fung nuen
carlo
and emmanuel okiki who did all of the
the bench work um for this and then
stephen gotcha who is the chair of our
department who's been
a friend and he's been my mentor for for
several
years now starting at baylor college of
medicine
now at texas children's many other
people in our department
our pathology group the immune
histochemistry standing alone took a
year to develop
incredible amount of credit to mike clay
julie justice and others
we have groups our ectl and gnp actively
translating this to clinical trial and
then everybody else from our oncology
departments biostats clinical research
and executive leadership who are really
providing the resources
and the support to move this and we do
expect to have the clinical trial open
at the end of the year or in the first
quarter of 2021 depending upon how
sort of coveted related delays affect
things moving forward
and with that i'm happy to take any
questions and again
thank you very much for allowing me to
present our data at this
this fantastic conference
um yama do you want to
chime in with uh questions or should i
just start answering questions as i
i see them down here
all right i will go right i see one
question says
great talk thank you do you think the
results are specific to b7 h3 car t
cells or could this be different
targeting um a different antigen
that i would say definitively that it
could be different targeting
other antigens as
as this construct is even in our own lab
is we've tested it targeting glyphocan 2
using this same
sort of four basic structure design and
we see different results so targeting
other antigens
unfortunately we can't predict
beforehand what will be the best
hinge transmembrane co-stem domains and
then
second genetic modifications
okay i'm sorry chris i finally got
unmuted i don't know if you can hear me
now
i can hear you yeah
i was screaming and yelling and speaking
to myself here but i finally got unmuted
so
there are definitely a number of
questions and then i apologize for
uh that uh technical hiccup but anyways
um
just to the audience uh we will now
start the question and answer portion of
the webinar
if you have any questions and you would
like to ask please submit it uh
right now we already got one question
answered so thank you for that chris for
taking the initiative
to to answer that and we'll try to get
to as many questions as uh
possible before the end of the hour and
certainly if we cannot
we'll make sure that we forward those
questions to chris
and get back to you so uh so anyways uh
lots of uh yeah so thank you very much
chris again for that
really really interesting and
fascinating talk
um just uh let's start kind of talking
in
general um from someone that's working
in the car t
field if you identify
an antigen that you want to kind of go
after
um just just in general
how many car constructs would one need
to really generate
to cover all the different permutations
do you is there like a specific number
that one would feel comfortable with
yeah yeah that's a great question if i
understand correctly it's
if we find this great new target how
many constructs do we want
you know can we possibly make or do we
need to make to figure out which is the
best one
to bring forward clinically um
i think one simple answer is it depends
upon the amount of resources especially
people that you have to generate the
constructs and test them
um yeah it's not incredibly expensive in
regards to
research terms but
the long answer is very difficult as you
can have
unlimited permutations i only showed
one two different hinge trans membrane
and two cosine domains
and there are many others that that may
be better or maybe worse
and of course each adding each one you
don't simply add the number you multiply
the
sort of number of constructs you're
using so i have no simple answer to that
question other than
we take our best educated
guess or opinion based on previous work
and we stick to what's been used
clinically and
and use those permutations um i wish i
had a more
clear answer but it could be unlimited
and uh there is no no solid number of
how many you should test
um yeah thank you yeah thank you chris
uh
i i've always uh was kind of sort of
wondering about that whether it is kind
of like uh
some systematic approach or whether uh
you know as you said it really kind of
depends on how much is really known
historical data and and uh and and all
of that
so uh let's uh get back to this um
assay that you've performed on the
excelligence system this sort of
repetitive killing which is really
fascinating
and so so clearly
you start to see differences maybe after
the third or the fourth
round of doing these killing assays for
specific types of
constructs the question here is that
have you actually looked at the
absolute cell number of car t cells
as you're passaging or taking the cells
from one one experiment to the other and
is there
any relationship with the number of uh
car t cells
and extent to which they will ultimately
kill
kill the target tumor cells
yeah that's a perfect question and that
is often
a a critique i would say that i get when
um giving this talker similar so the the
question is you know when we do the
repeat tumor challenge
um at least the way that i take the
question do we count the t cells and
then
replace the the same number as the
beginning or do we simply take all of
them and move them to the
tumor cells so the short answer
is we take all of the t cells that are
there
and transfer to a new well with targets
and some people prefer to
take them out count and stimulate with
the same number
of t cells that started with so
people often critique and say you only
have this extra killing because you have
increased numbers of t cells and the way
that i look at it is always from a
translational
sort of clinical perspective and while
this is certainly not a human
and it's not an in vivo system if the
initial proliferation provides the
benefit
and that is what's helping over time you
know to me that
that shows the difference and it is
relevant and
if you take it down and you decrease to
one million cells or your same as you're
starting you might find different
results and
and we can easily do that but at least
to me
i think this is the most relevant way to
do it
because in humans once you infuse the t
cell the goal is they proliferate at
sites of tumor
and repeatedly kill um
but that could certainly be argued
against um
maybe best is to do it both ways and and
show
um how it might differ great question
great yeah thank you thank you for that
chris
so uh when we're talking about inter
about
in vitro assays for characterizing um
these car t cells you know you talked
about
obviously immune cell killing which
you're using the excellent system
you talked about um cytokine
cytokine production as kind of another
way to look at that
and you also uh kind of mentioned about
looking at exhaustion of these uh these
cells
uh as well uh by by the way that you've
sort of done your experiments um is
there
anything else that one can do in
in vitro in addition to looking at
the potency of immune cell killing
exhaustion uh what about let's say
persistence is there a way to kind of
address that
by in vitro methods yeah
another fantastic question that is you
know
pretty clear across the field looking at
any car t
cell type is what other test
in vitro can we use to
predict if car t cells will work better
in in vivo or
or in humans you mentioned
exhaustion a couple of times so
exhaustion i use as
a functional definition and i'm glad
that you recognize that
so a lot of times people will use flow
cytometry markers you know pd1 tim 3 lag
3 which i think is completely
fine but people should know those are
also activation markers
and just because car t cells express
them doesn't mean the t
cells don't kill anymore so i prefer
a functional definition of repeat
killing and now they're not functioning
other people use interferon gamma
secretion repeatedly
so in addition to that there are sort of
methods and what some of our
collaborators here are doing and we're
starting to work with
is methylation profiling
is getting a lot of attention in the car
t cell field
and if you do methylation profiling you
can actually
predict donors that have more naive like
t
cells so the memory phenotype central
memory and naive predict better outcomes
in patients
whether that's true for patients with
solid tumors we don't know
but methylation profiling is becoming a
new way
to sort of tell us predict how well t
cells were
persist in vivo we certainly don't know
in humans but
us and a lot of other groups are
collaborating to work on that
um
you know what i didn't show we look at
memory phenotypes they're similar
between all the car t
cells so that didn't tell us anything
different
but a lot of the work is sort of on the
phenotype of the t cells and
where does that stem from and it comes
from patients treated with cd19 car t
cells and you take patients who
responded versus not responded
and you look at the phenotype the memory
phenotype of the cells infused
compared to how well the patients did
and that sort of set off this whole
field of
more naive central memory like
i wished i wish there was a perfect test
or even better to
test in vitro but it really has to be a
combination of these carefully evaluated
studies
and so far no but
hopefully us and others can come up with
better tests
and we're always working on that
fantastic that's uh that's great chris
um
so uh let's uh let's talk about some of
these uh
constructs that you mentioned and the
fact that
basically both in in in vitro studies
and
animal models uh finally you managed to
see
uh really good efficacy with this
four one we 1vb ligand uh
and in addition to the car uh car
constructs and and
and expressing that so um i guess the
question here is
when you are introducing multiple
different constructs into these t-cells
does that pose any sort of a challenge
as opposed to just expressing a car
a single car construct in terms of
the workflow and then and everything
else that's associated with it
yeah but another fantastic question
these are
you know these are right on point with
the most important
questions in the field so does adding
sort of what we call a second genetic
modification the forum bb ligand produce
any new challenges the short answer is
yes
and the reason being that we can only
package so many
base pairs of dna into viral particles
so once we get to about 10 kb
of our plasmid size you really can't
add anything more to what will transduce
the cars with
and if remember from my slide which i
don't expect anybody
to it also where you place the
constructs in relation to one another
so in our 401 bb ligand construct it's
upstream
of the car you know most of the time we
expect higher expression
of the upstream molecule even though we
use a 2a sequence and there
should be one to one we want a very high
expression of the 401 bb ligand
and we actually got high expression of
both so that another
variable is you have limited package
size
the other variable is once you have two
modifications
they may affect the function of the
other we got lucky and this happened to
work
in many other instances the second
genetic modification doesn't work and
then you have to test out
10 or more different confirmations
and then sort of but i think the
critical question that sort of follows
along this is how many
how many things can we introduce into a
car t cell right
now if we need to go over the plasmid
size of about 10 kb
you would need to transduce with two
separate plasmids
so at least in my opinion you can
probably have about three genetic
modifications either by
doing dual transductions or on another
method
using sort of crispr cas9 deletions and
then
transduction many groups have worked on
you know providing so-called backpacks
of cytokines
that t cells can physically carry um
so all of these methods hopefully
there's a breakthrough that allows us to
introduce
more than three or so modifications at
once
because as as you bring up very astutely
each one we add
poses its own challenges
and and they are many if um if it is too
big we'll get very low
transduction and um you know simply
won't function
in clinical trials thank you for that's
a great question
yeah thank you chris um the the
the the other question that i wanted to
also
sort of pose to you so you you know you
talked about car
engineering or car t engineering and and
then the different modifications and all
of that and at least from that
perspective
you can only do so much to what extent
in your mind is the actual
conditions for manufacturing
these car t's ultimately for for
for patient use uh to what extent
is that important as as in as much as
like let's say engineer car engineer
cartoon engineering and
in in all of that for example the media
components of
how you grow these cells and um
any possible differentiation into
different lineages and all of that
if you can maybe perhaps kind of
enlighten us with what what what
you may think about that oh that is
that is one of the most important things
now the question is
how does our pre-clinical question you
know our media
and our conditions compare to our our
gmp
and then sort of you know how closely do
they resemble one another and if there's
differences
at least in my opinion you know how do
we know they'll work
that is a is a very hot topic
and if the short answer is
the gmp conditions that are different
affected very much
and we have to be very careful that when
we translate something from
the bench where we use less expensive
media
and fetal bovine serum instead of human
serum albumin and sort of less expensive
materials that are easier
to use does
the translation to the gmp affect cd4
cd8 ratios does it affect memory
phenotype
does it affect cytotoxicity once we
transfer
to the gmp we actually have a group at
st drew that is the intermediary
so we take this very seriously and we
try to mimic gmp conditions once we've
sort of picked our construct as much as
possible
and then really it's it's almost
starting over
confirming that it all works the same as
we found before
and and you cannot presume that what you
find
in your laboratory will work in a gmp
setting
[Music]
and more and more this is you know the
fda when we submit pre-ind they want to
know
exactly what are the differences in our
media and
they want us to go back and test
everything in the media that will be
used in the gmp
and that is an incredibly correct
request for us
we're doing it we're finding very
similar results
uh but critically important if you make
changes and you presume that it will
work the same
unfortunately we'll be will be wrong it
just will not
every change makes a difference
okay well uh with that i think
we are reaching the top of the hour
thanks again chris for a really
fantastic talk
and and sort of enlightening us also
with
kind of the car t field and then some of
the challenges
that people are faced with in this in
this field to make these
therapies a reality uh i appreciate it
thank you very much and we look forward
to having you again
in a future uh conference great thank
you for the opportunity
thank you